a hundred days of uh
war
uh 100 days of suffering devastation
destruction
and a massive scale
uh 100 days of unabated warfare
and 100 days of life's laws and people
uprooted the lives of millions have been
shattered
at least 15.7 million people in ukraine
are now in urgent need of humanitarian
assistance and protection
numbers are rising by the day as the war
continues ravage uh
and with winter around the corner where
millions of people may be exposed
because of the destruction the power
points poor plants
fuel the boats
and uh expected uh freezing temperature
in this part of the world
the impact of the water across the
region and the world is profound
there are 1.4 billion people that can be
affected because of the shortage of
wheat and other grains
the the export of food from from ukraine
and fertilizer from russia impacted the
world negatively and created inflation
uh food crisis especially in for a
united states and state in transition in
the sahel of africa in the horn of
africa but also in populist nations
and
the crisis continues to deepen
the solution to this mass demand and
urgent support require political will an
unblocking trade rules in the black sea
must remain the priority failure to open
those ports will result in famine
destabilization and mass migration
around the world so the black sea ports
are as it were the silver bullet when it
comes to avoiding global famines global
hunger but if that silver bullet isn't
found we also need those alliances to
support overland deliveries of food
exporting from this country a country
that fed 400 million people last year
through the eu through the north to the
to the baltic and also any means
possible through the black sea through
their own ports or through neighboring
ports um realistically though
we know this war is going to continue um
unfortunately for quite some time to
come perhaps with no winners no losers
everybody is going to lose though in
terms of what this country is already
facing and has lost in terms of jobs
industry safety security and humanity
thank you